ready oh yeah the bastard sword it was
wielded by jon snow
it'll kill
the epi to combat gentlemen this blade
can be seen wielded by arya stark from
game of thrones
the famous sword needle wielded by arya
stark in the game of thrones series
draws its inspiration from the epic
combat an unassuming but vicious sword
designed primarily for thrusting the
blade's lightweight and needle point
allowed for deadly thrusts as arya
inflicted vengeance upon her enemies the
epitome combat also featured a guard to
protect the user's hand a necessary
feature for the weapon arya used in her
quest to avenge the stark family
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
i will take your weapon and deliver some
thrust and slashes on our
dummy from the north
trevor you're up first you ready for
this i'm ready let's do it
so
all right trevor first up it is so light
just like a needle
your point here allows for a very deep
penetration without any effort overall
sir it'll kill
good job all right victor your turn so
you ready
let's do this
[Music]
all right victor song about your sword
here it's not very light
overall though it's pointy enough to
thrust
the edge with the weight cuts
and
it will kill
thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test
to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades just like an
ice pick i'm going to be chipping ice
trevor you up first you ready i'm ready
okay trevor you did pick up a slight
bend in your tip
having said that i mean
this thing is so light
which is fantastic thank you
all right victor you are up are you
ready sir ready
uh
[Music]
victor
first off blade is
the same shape as when we started out
tip's still there it's fine
your fullers are there but they're not
very deep
and by not having them very deep this
this blade is is very heavy uh having
said that it's a strong blade it took no
damage so well done thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test the steel can stab and
water bag slice
i will take your weapon i'm going to
test the tip by thrusting into the cans
and i'm going to slash the bag
sorry up first you ready i'm ready let's
do this
[Music]
all right trevor no issues at all in
stabbing the can and the cut with your
tip on that bag you can see it's
straight cut all the way through overall
sir
it'll cut thank you
all right victor your turns are you
ready ready let's do this
all right victor first up in the
stabbing test on one of the thrusts it
pushed the cannon more than penetrated
all the way through but your edge is
sharp on the bag cut cleaning all the
way through and more importantly
he will cut thank you
all right gentlemen i finished my
discussion with your judges and they've
made their final decision our new forest
and fire champion is
trevor congratulations you're the new
force of fire champion
victor unfortunately your blade didn't
make the cut by the narrowest of margins
and david baker is going to tell you why
victor the eppy to combat was supposed
to be a lightning fast thrusting sword
the weight of your blade led it to be
just a more difficult weapon to use
that's why we're letting you go
[Music]
victor unfortunately today your blade
doesn't make the cut i'd like to invite
you to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then please leave
the forge
first thing i do when i go home kiss the
wife my son and start forging and get
ready for my next knife show
trevor congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10 000
good job brother come on forward my
friend
good job i can't believe that i
won forged in fire feeling better than
good the most fun i've had in years with
the ten thousand dollars i
i may buy a new sander
mostly will go to my wife though
the bastard sword
the bastard sword was widely popular
throughout europe during the middle ages
well into the renaissance
it's so well known a version of this
deadly blade was wielded by the famous
bastard jon snow in hbo's game of
thrones
while its blade length varied from 36 to
40 inches the name came from its
uniquely sized handle that was between
one and two hands long earning its
alternative name the hand and a half
sword lethal in battle the sword could
easily deliver devastating blows with
two hands or quickly inflict slashes in
close quarter combat with one all right
gentlemen you know what time it is it's
time for the kill test
i'm going gonna take your swords i'm
gonna attack this gel torso here see
what kind of damage we do
hunter you're up first are you ready yes
sir okay i'm so excited for this moment
come on baby
very cool man
[Music]
yeah i think he's done
all right hunter right off
it's a performer he cut deep on each one
of those cuts as a matter of fact that
one downward diagonal goes all the way
through the rib cage handle could have
been just a little bit longer i'm
winding up with about a hand and a
quarter instead of a hand and a half
but you definitely got a lethal blade
here thank you
all right phillip you're up you ready
ready
oh my gosh
very cool very cool
so
right off i like the scale of your blade
i mean it's very large but and it's got
a lot of weight to it but the balance is
nice you can see all these cuts are so
deep i was actually worried on that last
one that i would hit the post that's
holding that thing up but uh as far as
being a cutting sword this thing is
lethal good job thank you
you having fun doing this oh yeah making
history feeling good so what's up next
you ready for this we're going to test
the strength of your swords
you ready jay oh yeah very cool
thank you sir
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
the wwe bash fest
to test the edge holding ability and
overall construction
i'm going to go through a series of wwe
weapons we're going to destroy the table
puncture and dash through the garbage
can and just tear that ladder to pieces
conor you're first you ready to go yes
sir all right let's do it
jay steal the show brother
[Music]
[Music]
oh man
hunter you started out strong man oh
this is actually very comfortable even
though the handle is a little bit short
but
you look at the grain it looks like sand
so that caused a weak point and the
shock wave went all the way down and
snapped it at this weak point
sorry man
my heart
honor it's painful to see man you put a
lot of work into that thing and it looks
great but unfortunately you did have a
catastrophic failure on the ladder which
means we can't test your blade any
further but you are not out of fight yet
philip in order to claim the title
you've got to make it through the table
you got to make it through all the
swings through the trash can and you've
got to make it through at least one bash
into the ladder you're prepared for it
i'm nervous but i'm ready
whoo
get in the spirit man
let's see what your blade can do jake
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hold on
hunter man you fought hard the first
rounds you excelled but unfortunately
during the testing you did suffer
catastrophic failure and for that reason
time the forge has ended i'm gonna have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor bud
thank you honor
thank you guys
thank you very much well philip you know
what that means man you are the forge
and fire champion philip congratulations
man
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars as well as a wwe title
here we go man you got 10 grand
get out of this man's way
original fire champion brother
this title
is going in the most obnoxious spot of
the living room that i can find probably
taped onto the tv
let me hear it one time
whoa
the boar spear
developed as early as 700 a.d in europe
the boar spear was forged for both
combat and hunting known at the time as
a bar spare the weapon was about five to
six feet long and featured a pair of
lugs below the leaf-shaped blade when
hunting the lugs would stop a speared
boar from running up the length of the
weapon and attacking the user
in combat the lugs can be used to hook
and pull away enemy shields
the blade of the spear can be decorated
with some featuring finally engraved
scenes of hunts
on the first season of game of thrones
king robert baratheon carried a boar
spear on his final boar hunt
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
to see how sharp your boar spears are we
will test the tip and the edge by
stabbing and slashing through these
sandbags all right clayton you're up
first you ready i'm ready
well clayton the balance of your tip
lends itself to stabbing your edge
lacerated cleanly on a moving sandbag
what surprised me was the positioning of
your lug traditionally they have it
crosswise this way but you have it this
way because of that it was hard to index
when you're cutting through but then
again it will cut
thank you
alan you're next ready oh yeah
well alan
your spear feels good to hold on to it
was easy to index and know where the
edge was so that was a nice slash that i
could penetrate through and in the
thrust it felt good in the hand
all right i can see a little bow in your
handle
but when we're talking about the
sharpness test
this sir will cut all right
next stop is a kill test
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon can do i will deliver lethal
blows to this wild boar carcass dating
europe first are you ready absolutely
well clayton
your boar spear right here did very well
on the thrust penetrating all the way
through on the low line and on the high
line
on the edge
lacerate it cleanly
and testing the other side it cut all
the way through the spine
this sir
will kill good job thank you
alan you're next you ready oh yeah let's
do this
[Music]
well let's talk about your blade
on the thrust it penetrated all the way
through
on the laceration on one side of your
edge boy wow
it almost sliced all the way through
on your other edge
it lacerated through the spine
this piercer will kill all right
next up is a strength test dave
gentlemen it's been said that the sword
is the prince of all weapons but the
spear is the king to test the strength
of your bore spears i'm going to load
them into our air cannon here and fire
them into this wooden target it's a fun
test
thrilled to see it go down
i just can't wait we'll see how deep it
penetrates how well it holds up and if
it holds up while i remove the spear
from the target awesome clayton you're
up first you ready i am all right let's
do this
oh man i'm just hoping that my handle
stays together i'm hoping that after it
impacts the wood that it doesn't break
the blade off or something like that
in
three
two
one
phew
well clayton your spear really dug in
deep it went in about four inches came
out fine everything's still
tight and dialed in this is interesting
being off set being that it's a boar
spirit i wanted to make sure that
whatever laceration the blade produced
on the animal wasn't wide enough to
allow the wings to come through and the
best way to do that was just make them
perpendicular
all right nicely done thank you
alan you're up
in three
two
one
[Music]
all right alan that buried itself quite
nicely went into about
there again about four inches deep like
the leaf shape on this i like the fact
that you hand hammered the socket i was
kind of worried when i put this in our
machine that slight warp in your shaft
there would bind up
but
not a problem
good job
thank you
bladesmiths the judges have completed
their deliberation and they've made a
final decision both of you have turned
in
fantastic bore spears
however in this arena of competition
there can only be one forged and fire
champion
allen congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion
congratulations you did awesome
clayton
your boar spirit did not make the cut
clayton this was not an easy decision to
make because of your perpendicular lugs
it was hard to visually index your blade
meaning it's hard to tell where the
cutting edge is that makes it a less
effective weapon
before that we have to let you go i
understand
clayton please surrender your weapon
right now obviously i'm a little bit
disappointed but this is the first spear
i made and for me it's really important
that it was such a tight race
i don't want it to be anything that i
handed him or anything that he would
have handed me alan is the deserving
champion
alan congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion and with that comes a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you
you know what i really appreciate about
that is the fact that you took the time
to actually hammer that cone out making
that socket is a really nice touch on
any kind of traditional spear well done
i am the fortune fire champion i cannot
believe it
i had no idea if it was going to be me
or him and
it was me i'm betting being a fortune
fire champion is going to help this
stay-at-home dad slash knife maker
convinced a few people that they should
try out my blades that's great
the egyptian kapesh
dating back to 2500 bc the kapesh was a
curved sickle sword adopted by egyptians
from the canaanites it was used to
execute their enemies as an infantry
weapon and also as a symbol of the
authority of their nobles
the unique shape of their curved blades
meant they could be used to hook a
shield snag an opponent's leg in an
attempt to trip them or even tangle an
opposing weapon
the weapon's distinctive design makes
the kapesh easily recognizable in
television series such as game of
thrones plane spins it is said that the
historic design of the copesh evolved
from a battle axe its edge was so sharp
that it said it could cut through just
about anything to test the sharpness of
your weapon i will see how well it cuts
through a sandbag
sugarcane and a rope sailing you up you
ready yes sir
well salem it definitely is easy enough
to cut through a sandbag cut through
sugar cane but the forward weight being
a little bit tip heavy was a little bit
harder to slice through on the upward
stroke but definitely it's a very sharp
weapon
this sir will cut good job thanks
craig you're up you ready yes sir
i'm just disappointed that it wouldn't
cut the rope
[Music]
well craig
it cut to a sandbag cut all the way
through three sugar canes but the same
idea on an upward swing for the test it
did lacerate the rope but it didn't cut
through
but overall
it will cut
now it's time to move on to the kill
test
to test the functionality and lethality
of your blade i will attempt to rip off
the shields then deliver killing blows
on this ballistic dummy let's see how
much damage your weapon can do salem
you're up you ready all right
the hook on your tip does allow to rip
off the shield
the edge you have right here cause some
serious damage
enough to cut all the way through the
belly here at the same time i've cut
through all these bones from the
clavicle to the ribs
this sir
kills
craig it's your turn you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
well craig
what i like about your particular hook
design over here is that as you puncture
twist and rip out everything that you
have in there will hook and come out
with it
the edge cut all the way into the bone
and broke these ribs to stir them this
sir
will kill
thank you
next up is a strength test dave
gentlemen what i'm going to do to test
the strength of your weapons is take
seven blows against these animal femurs
salem you're up are you ready great
now salem in examining your weapon we
noticed a small delamination on the back
of the blade
i was not expecting that i'm just hoping
that the edge stays hard so we're going
to keep an eye on that through the
testing and we'll see if it opens up
[Music]
well sailing that
that did a job on those bones now
there's a little bit of deflection on
your blade
but that back mark didn't open or split
at all
now you can see i went through two of
those bones
and was well into the third
well done thank you so craig it's your
turn you ready let's do it all right
[Music]
well craig you can see
a lot of chips right there in the impact
zone
the first few blows against those femurs
it started cutting really nicely broke
through the one but as we started to
lose edge here with those chips and
deflections it just stopped cutting and
it was more of a bludgeoning impact blow
but i felt it really cut well when i was
swinging it all in all nice design i
like your handle construction and it's
definitely a chopper
so gentlemen
good job
salem craig there can only be one forged
and fire champion
salem
you are the forged and fire champion
congratulations
good job thank you
good job to you too
craig unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
[Music]
greg thank you this experience was
harder than i thought it was gonna be
i need about three gin and tonics and
i'm just gonna make the bad man in the
back of my head go away
salem it's safe to smile now because
you're the forge and fire champion the
recipient of ten thousand dollars
congratulations
the fullers on that blade just really
bring that pattern out i think that's
really nice touch
it's just crazy
it's going to take a while to sink in
kind of stunned right now
the irish ring hilted sword
dating back to the 12th century the
irish ring-hilted sword was a classic
european weapon with a blade reaching
lengths of up to 40 inches the broad
double-edged weapon featured a
distinctive ring pommel that was key for
counterbalancing its weight allowing for
swift and deadly cuts commonly used by
the elite mercenaries known as gallo
glass the well-balanced sword
complemented their superior fighting
techniques that were revered throughout
ireland in the middle ages although
warriors such as the gallow glass no
longer exist the weapon symbolism is
still represented in popular culture
today and can be seen on the television
show game of thrones where one of the
most feared characters a mountain wields
his ring-hilted sword
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your irish ring hilton swords can do i
will take your weapon and deliver
killing blows on this feral bore carcass
jason europe first you ready i am let's
do this
[Music]
all right jason first up when i grab on
to it it feels good in the hand it's a
good fit
now swinging this
is sweet you have a very sharp edge that
cuts easily
into this wild boar carcass
it will kill
good job jason thank you all right sean
you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
all right sean let's talk about your
weapon right here first up when i
grabbed onto the handle it's got a good
feel to that i like that you put some
grooves in there because it fits nicely
to where my hand locks into it and i get
a very secure fit
a little heavier but the weight helps
push and cut into this wild boar carcass
and most of all
it will kill
thank you sir good job
ben
welcome to the strength test the dreaded
ice chop
to test the strength and durability of
your swords as well as their overall
construction i'm going to be chopping
mercilessly into this unforgiving block
of ice
remember this test is all about what
that ice does to your ring hilted swords
and not what your swords do the ice
chasing europe first you ready yeah go
ahead good
well jason first things first the warp i
think that it being off center made it
rotate in my hand but the balance on
this sword as you can see is beautiful
it's comfortable to wield and it's short
held up well done thank you sean you're
up how you feeling
nervous but excited all right let's do
it
[Applause]
nice
well sean
the weight on this is a little tip heavy
i would have liked a little bit more
counter balance on it but that being
said it's still a lot of fun to swing
your edge held up beautifully
everything's
right and tight
well done thank you sir
next up is the shortness test and for
that i give you to dave
okay gentlemen now to test the sharpness
of your blade i'll be cutting through
this sugar cane i'll use both edges of
your blade now unlike the strength test
this is all about what your blades do to
that target i want to see those cuts
nice and clean that cane's broken or
pushed out of the way chasing you up
first you ready i am okay
[Music]
all right just your handle construction
you can see how square that is right
there
when that was in my backhand cut
i actually got into those canes and then
it rolled
your tang is now kind of kicking off to
one side
so that probably happened
as that blade caught that last cane and
yanked down
but uh definitely a sharp blade really
nice
sean you're up are you ready yes sir
okay
[Music]
nice
okay
first up your handle construction i like
a lot it's not rotating in my hand
it's a heavier sword
but uh cuts are clean it's definitely a
sharp blade i like that hold on thank
you
jason sean the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision
the next forest and fire champion is
[Music]
sean
congratulations you're the new forged
and fire champion jason unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut please
surrender your blade
i would have liked it one
but uh i'm proud of what i've done i
mean throughout this whole series of
tests
i made a strong sharp blade and it
performed equally as well so
i'm happy with it
sean congratulations you're the new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel about
that it doesn't suck
that way does not
sean please present your blade to the
judges
this whole experience it's pushed me
physically it's pushed me mentally
parts of it have been pretty brutal
thank you guys and i wouldn't trade a
minute of it for anything i've had the
time of my life
you